und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Marietta Slomka guten
Abend hast du Streit in deiner Koalition
hilft es ungemein wenn man zu Lösung
tief in die Tasche greifen kann nimm du
das dafür kriege ich das in einer 3er
Koalition gibt es im Zweifelsfall noch
mehr unterschiedliche Begehrlichkeiten
das Problem ist nur das Geld wird gerade
knapper die steuerschätze haben heute
ihre Prognosen vorgelegt und demnach
fließt nächstes Jahr deutlich weniger in
die Staatskassen als ursprünglich
erwartet das liegt vor allem daran dass
in der Zwischenzeit eine Steuerreform
zum Inflationsausgleich beschlossen
wurde diese in Anführungsstrichen
Mindereinnahmen von der Bundesregierung
also selbst gewollt waren ändert aber
nichts daran dass sich der Streit über
den Bundeshaushalt dadurch noch
verschärft
wie Finanzminister Lindner das vom
g7-treffen in Japan aus kommentiert hat
Daniel pontzen beobachtet
nigata an der Westküste Japans ist eine
Stadt die reich ist ein Tradition die
schon viel gesehen hat und sich auf
alles so gewissenhaft vorbereitet das
auch diese Premiere niemanden aus der
Ruhe bringt eine deutsche
Steuerschätzung vorgetragen vom
deutschen Finanzminister gut 12
Flugstunden entfernt von der deutschen
hauptstadtergebnis eröffnet gegenüber
den bisherigen Planungen keinerlei neuen
finanziellen Handlungsspielräume es
bleibt deshalb das Gebot der Stunde die
Konsolidierung des Bundeshaushaltes
voranzutreiben und sehr streckt sich auf
Prioritäten zu verständigen dass er das
Vortragen der Zahlen und vor allem deren
Interpretation sich auch so fern der
Heimat im Kreise der G7 nicht nehmen
lässt und damit zusammen dass sie neben
dieser Heimat der Streit um den Haushalt
zu eskalieren droht denn die
zusätzlichen ausgabewünsche seiner
Kabinettskollegen verlierten sich
zuletzt aufgrund 70 Milliarden Euro so
forderte zum Beispiel
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius
rund 10 Milliarden mehr was doppelt
teuer würde denn Svenja Schulze will
gemäß Koalitionsvertrag eins zu eins
dasselbe für Entwicklungshilfe
Familienministerin dieser Praus verlangt
12 Milliarden extra für die
Kindergrundsicherung und Außenministerin
Werbung will ebenfalls nicht verzichten
etwa auf Klimaschutz und Kulturprojekte
in aller Welt nun aber sind die Zahlen
schlechter als noch zuletzt im Oktober
geschätzt 13 Milliarden weniger sind ist
demnach für den Boden zu allein nächstes
Jahr also Prioritäten durch das dies für
jeden in der Ampel etwas anderes
bedeutet das bedeutet soziales und
Klimaschutz die soziale wärmewende muss
finanziert werden und die Kinder
Grundsicherung muss ebenfalls aus
finanziert werden und dann gab es von
den Grünen noch eine Ermahnung gegen
Japan mit Blick auf Lindners
Zeitmanagement der Finanzminister ist
verantwortlich dafür einen Zeitplan
vorzulegen wir brauchen einen
einigungsfähigen Entwurf bis zum Sommer
muss er jetzt bringen dass es seine
Verantwortung nachdem Lindner im März
bereits die sonst üblichen Eckwerte
abgesagt hatte erklärte er nun den für
Mitte Juni erwarteten Kabinettsentwurf
werde es erst später geben
Angriffsfläche für die Opposition es
reicht eigentlich wie katastrophal der
Zustand der Ampel oder ich sag mal der
ampelpartner untereinander ist dass sie
sich über ihren Regierungsplan für das
kommende Jahr nicht einig werden können
das zeigt wie desolat der Zustand dieser
Regierung mittlerweile ist Rückendeckung
erhält Lindner wie zuletzt häufiger
schon aus der SPD samt Appell dieser
Haushalt dieser Haushaltsaufstellung ist
schwierig viel schwieriger als in den
letzten 10 Jahren das stimmt aber es
gibt in einem großen Haushalt immer
Möglichkeiten und ich sehe auch in
diesem Haushalt 24 viele Möglichkeiten
wenn man pragmatisch und sagt orientiert
dann die Dinge herangehen vielleicht ist
es der Rückhalt seines Vorgängers von
Kanzler Olaf Scholz das ist ein Lindner
jedenfalls wird demonstrat IV gelassen
fast so gelassen wie niegate diese
deutsche Steuerschätzung und all das was
dran hängt hinter sich gebracht hat
aus der Sicht von Finanzministern ist
die Kassenlage ja eigentlich immer knapp
allein schon aus pädagogischen Gründen
damit die Wünsche der Kabinettskollegen
nicht überhand nehmen man erinnert sich
jedenfalls nicht daran dass ein
Finanzminister Jenseits spezieller
Krisensituationen mal von sich aus mit
den Geldscheinen wedelt nehmt Leute ich
habe es gerade dicke
aber wenn es politisch opportun ist
findet sich natürlich immer noch eine
Milliarde hier oder da so wie gestern
beim flüchtlingsgipfel mit den
Bundesländern für große Begeisterung
sorgt dass bei Ländern und Gemeinden
allerdings nicht die lass wohnsack
berichtet die Gemeinde Wiernsheim in
Baden-Württemberg tut einiges um
Flüchtlinge unterzubringen ein Gasthof
wurde renoviert Wohnungen sind
angemietet eine ausgediente Kita
umgebaut dennoch sieht der Bürgermeister
seine Kommune überlastet überlasteten
der Form dass eben die Arbeitskraft
umgesetzt werden muss auf das Thema
Flüchtlinge dass vieles anderes liegen
bleibt und dadurch natürlich auch ein
großes Unverständnis in der Bevölkerung
langsam herrscht Unverständnis herrscht
auch beim deutschen Städte und
Gemeindebund die eine Milliarde Euro die
der Bund gestern noch mal locker gemacht
hat würde nicht reichen die Kommunen
brauchten bei erwartbar steigenden
geflüchteten Zahlen langfristige
Planungssicherheit
natürlich ist eine Milliarde auch Geld
aber das ist eben eine Milliarde für
dieses Jahr was ist nächstes Jahr die
Kommunen bauen jetzt
Unterkünfte sie müssen wissen was wird
wann wie von wem bezahlt nichts weniger
als eine Zeitenwende sollte der
migrationsgipfel bringen heraus kam nur
eine einmalige Zahlung und eine
Arbeitsgruppe
wir haben heute einen ersten Schritt
gemacht und wir haben einen Fahrplan mit
einem Zwischenbericht im Juni und eine
Entscheidung im November verabredet
mehr war eben nicht drin das muss man
heute so klar sagen das Thema
geflüchtete bietet sich als Futter für
die Opposition während CDU-Chef März
davor warnt dass Deutschland in eine
neue migrationskrise schlittern könnte
ist die für die AFD längst da mit mehr
Geld löst man dieses Problem nicht und
das Problem ist dass wir natürlich diese
Zuwanderung begrenzen müssen dass wir
diese Herunterfahren müssen dass wir
versuchen müssen pull Faktoren endlich
zu beenden also das heißt dass wir
umstellen müssen von Geld auf
Sachleistungen wenig gehört in den
letzten Wochen aber es gibt sie noch
diejenigen die auf die andere Seite
schauen so verweist der
baden-württembergische Flüchtlingsrat
auf das Grundrecht auf Asyl in
Deutschland wenn man sich das Beschluss
Papier durchliest dann fällt glaube ich
einmal der Begriff Deutschland muss
seiner humanitären Verpflichtungen
gerecht werden und ansonsten liest man
15 Seiten lang schlimmste
abschottungsmaßnahmen die das Ziel haben
das geflüchtete Menschen überhaupt nicht
erst nach Europa gelangen sollen die
einzige die sich heute umfassend
freundlich zu den Ergebnissen äußert ist
diejenige die für große Teile der
Flüchtlingspolitik verantwortlich
zeichnet wir sind als Bundesregierung
damit angetreten eine Veränderung in der
Migrationspolitik vorzunehmen das
spiegelt sich auch ein Stück weit in
diesem Beschluss wieder nämlich auf der
einen Seite legen alle einreisewege nach
Deutschland zu ermöglichen auf der
anderen Seite aber auch diejenigen die
leider kein Recht haben hier zu bleiben
auch wieder effektiv zurückzuführen über
längerfristige Lösungen soll im November
entschieden werden und so lautet das
Resümee auch diesmal wieder nach dem
Gipfel ist vor dem Gipfel
aber wir sprechen mit unserer Hauptstadt
korrespondentinischer energy also wenn
der Plan war das Thema zu befrieden dann
hat das wohl eher nicht geklappt oder
ja bei der Grundfrage wie man dauerhaft
und langfristig mit der Kostenverteilung
bei der Versorgung von Flüchtlingen
umgeht da brotet es tatsächlich immer
noch aber heute hatte man hier in Berlin
schon den Eindruck dass zumindest die
Schärfe raus ist aus der Diskussion mit
der Bund und Länder zuvor aufeinander
losgegangen waren der Bund hat anerkannt
dass die gemeinsame Versorgung von
geflüchteten eine Daueraufgabe ist und
die Länder haben auf der anderen Seite
gewürdigt dass der Bund schon sehr viel
tut und sie haben die neue Gangart bei
der Migrationspolitik insgesamt
mitgetragen und dabei das hat dann den
Weg frei gemacht dafür dass man sich
eben der umstrittenen Frage wer sich in
welcher Form und wie lange an der
Versorgung von geflüchteten beteiligt
zumindest im nächsten Schritt dann noch
einmal weniger emotional besprechen kann
ja Stichwort neue Gangart einige
Vorschläge die jetzt zum Ministerin
Faser kommen die hatte in ähnlicher Form
wenn auch und andere Tonlage schon ihr
Vorgänger Haus Seehofer propagiert ja
und das bringt Teile von SPD und die
Grünen hier tatsächlich auch auf die
Palme weil es eben an alte Zeiten
erinnert da kann man vor allem zwei
Punkte nennen das sind zum Bein zum
einen die Asylzentren an in der Nähe von
EU-Außengrenzen das hat die SPD in der
großen Koalition immer sehr hart
abgelehnt ähnlich auch wie die wie
verlängerte abschieberhaft beides wird
jetzt nicht nur von der Bundesregierung
mitgetragen sondern auch von SPD
regierten Bundesländern dass der sorgt
für Kritik vom linken Flügel der SPD und
vor allem für die Grünen ist das ganze
eine riesengroße Herausforderung weil es
ein paar Grundüberzeugungen in Frage
stellt die Grünen haben gestern noch mal
ein eigenes Papier vorgelegt zu einer
menschenrechtsorientierten ähm
Migrationspolitik und das hat eben ein
ganz anderen Zungenschlag als das was
jetzt auf der auf der großen Liste dort
steht da gibt es eine große Unruhe in
der in der Partei und aus der
Bundestagsfraktion hört man schon das
was an diesem von diesen Vorschlägen
durch den Bundestag muss das wird man
sich da sehr genau ansehen also da steht
der Ampel noch eine umfassende Debatte
vor danke schön nach Berlin
und zu dem Thema diskutiert nachher auch
Madrid Illner mit ihren Gästen
eines ist auch klar wenn Kommunen nicht
mehr wissen wohin mit geflüchteten dann
hilft mehr Geld auch nur bedingt so
schnell baut man keine Wohnungen und
containerdörfer sind keine Dauerlösung
unabhängig von der Flüchtlingsfrage war
der Wohnungsbau ihr eigentlich eines der
großen Themen die diese Koalition
anpacken wollte tatsächlich ist das
Gegenteil eingetreten es wird viel
weniger gebaut das war Hauptthema auf
dem heute in Berlin begonnenen
baukongress die Gründe sind vielfältig
gestiegene Zinsen gestiegene Baukosten
und große Teile der KfW-Förderung
praktisch weggefallen selbst Bauvorhaben
die schon genehmigt sind liegen auf Eis
berichtet Dominik Müller Russell
Mühlheim im Ruhrgebiet es bewegt sich
nicht viel auf dem Baugrundstück der
Mülheimer Wohnungsgenossenschaft
eigentlich sollten hier 40 Reihenhäuser
gebaut werden doch das Vorhaben zu teuer
geworden gestoppt kamen im Ruhrgebiet
eigentlich sollten auf diesem ehemaligen
Polizeigelände 90 Wohnungen entstehen
doch das Projekt ebenfalls auf weiß und
auch in Duisburg wird auf diesem
Baugrundstück erst mal kein Haus mit
Mietwohnungen gebaut das Haus die
Wohnungen sind nicht mehr finanzierbar
die Kosten sind explodiert die Mieten
sind einfach nicht mehr bezahlbar die
sich aus den aktuellen Baupreisen
ergeben hinzukommt dass sich die
Finanzierungskosten deutlich verteuert
haben und die energetischen
Anforderungen verteuern das Bauen enorm
wobei wir auch nicht genau wissen welche
energetischen Anforderungen welche
Technologien wir einsetzen können um die
umzusetzen die Gesetzgebung die
Förderlandschaft ist da einfach im
Moment
unberechenbar immer höhere Anforderungen
an Neubauten was heizen Dämmung und
Entlüftungsanlagen betrifft und auf der
anderen Seite weniger bundesfördermittel
leiden müssten darunter vor allem sozial
schwächere aber auch die Mitte der
Gesellschaft kritisiert die Branche wenn
70 80% von Neubauprojekten erstmal auf
Eis liegen oder auch gänzlich
unterbleiben dann betrifft es
insbesondere den bezahlbaren
mietwohnungsraum und das spüren
natürlich insbesondere die
Mieterhaushalte junge Familien
Studierende
Alleinerziehende die insbesondere auch
bezahlbare Mieten angewiesen sind und
deswegen unser Appell an die Politik
hier gegen zu steuern ja das werde sie
verspricht heute bundesbauministerin
Klara Gallwitz bei einem Branchentreffen
in Berlin aber nicht durch mehr
Subventionen auf die viele hoffen
sondern wir müssen am Kern des Problems
ansetzen nämlich an den Baukosten die
müssen runter dazu müssen ganz viele
einzelne Maßnahmen gemacht werden
stellplatzsatzungen die nicht mehr in
unsere Zeit gehören oder aber die
Digitalisierung des kompletten Bereiches
vom Plan über die Genehmigung haben wir
einen großen Schritt voran gemacht Ende
des Jahres werden über die Hälfte der
bauordnungsämter in der Lage sein auch
ein digitalen Bauantrag anzunehmen so
soll schneller und damit günstiger
gebaut werden doch die Lage sei so
dringlich dass weitere Baunormen auf den
Prüfstand müssten fordern Experten man
könnte natürlich darüber nachdenken ob
an dem beispielsweise im sozialen
Wohnungsbau über geringere Neubau
Standards nachdenkt beispielsweise einem
Lärmschutz oder eben an anderen Auflagen
herangeht dir dann eben diesen Wohnungs
etwas günstiger machen als die anderen
Segmente mit Wohnungsnot und
gesellschaftlichen Verwerfungen rechnen
sie im Ruhrgebiet wenn bauen so teuer
bleibt es müsste wieder vorangehen
schnell
im heute journal Update dazu später noch
ein Gespräch mit dem Vizepräsidenten des
Deutschen Städtetags dem Leipziger ob
hat Johann und die Nachrichten beginnen
jetzt in der Ukraine Hanna ja der
ukrainische Präsident selenski hat sich
zu der seit langem erwarteten
Gegenoffensive geäußert diese werde sich
noch etwas verzögern denn das Land warte
auf zugesagte Ausrüstung erklärte
selenski in einem BBC Interview
unterdessen wurde bekannt dass
Großbritannien der Ukraine als erstes
Land Marschflugkörper mit größerer
Reichweite liefert die Raketen würden in
die Ukraine geschickt oder sein bereits
in ukrainischer Hand erklärte der
britische Verteidigungsminister sie
haben eine Reichweite von bis zu 250 km
2 Tage nach der Festnahme von Ex
Premierminister Kahn in Pakistan hat das
Oberste Gericht seine Freilassung
angeordnet zudem rief es die
anhängerkans auf friedlich zu bleiben
seit dessen Verhaftung gibt es
landesweit gewaltsame Proteste bei denen
bislang mindestens zehn Menschen ums
Leben kamen mittlerweile kommt auch das
Militär zum Einsatz dem
Oppositionsführer und früheren Tickets
da wird Korruption und Geldwäsche
vorgeworfen
kurz vor den Präsidentschaftswahlen in
der Türkei am Sonntag hat der Erdogan
Herausforderer inche überraschend seine
Kandidatur zurückgezogen in Shell selbst
wäre bei der wahlchancenlos gewesen doch
aus Sicht von Meinungsforschern könnte
sein Rückzug nun dem aussichtsreichen
Oppositionsführer kellage darogulu
helfen um fragen Sie in diesen aktuell
vorabendsinhaber Erdogan doch das Rennen
könnte knapp werden
die Zahl der Drogentoten in Deutschland
ist erneut angestiegen im vergangenen
Jahr starben fast 2000 Menschen durch
den Konsum illegaler Drogen das sind 9%
mehr als im Vorjahr der
Drogenbeauftragte der Bundesregierung
Lienert bezeichnete die Zahl als
schockierend und forderte einen
Kurswechsel in der Drogenpolitik bessere
Suchthilfe und mehr Prävention sein
nötig seit 2012 hat sich die Zahl der
Drogentoten mehr als verdoppelt eine der
Haupt Todesursachen sei herointonsum
bei einer Explosion in einem Hochhaus im
nordrhein-westfälischen Ratingen sind
neuen Feuerwehrleute und Polizisten
verletzt worden einige von ihnen
lebensgefährlich die Einsatzkräfte waren
in eine Hochhauswohnung gerufen worden
dort habe der 57-Jährige Bewohner dann
eine Explosion ausgelöst spezialkräfte
der Polizei stürmten anschließend die
Wohnung in der auch eine Leiche gefunden
wurde die Person soll schon länger tot
gewesen sein der Bewohner ist in
Gewahrsam die Hintergründe sind noch
unklar
am Sonntag wird gewählt nicht nur in der
Türkei auch hier bei uns im kleinsten
Bundesland Bremen das mag weltpolitisch
nicht ganz so viel Aufmerksamkeit auf
sich ziehen ist in Deutschland aber
natürlich auch wichtig die letzte
Bürgerschaftswahl verlief für die
regierende SPD ziemlich frustrierend
erstmals seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
wurde nicht sie sondern die CDU stärkste
Kraft durch ein Dreierbündnis mit Grünen
und Linken konnte sie sich aber an der
Macht halten
vier Jahre später sieht es so aus als
sei es Bürgermeister Andreas
bovenschulte gelungen SPD Wähler
zurückzuholen nach dem neuesten
Politbarometer extra für Bremen käme die
CDU auf 26 Prozent die SPD hätte die
Nase vorn mit 29 Prozent die bisherigen
Koalitionspartner Grüne und Linke kämen
auf 13 und 11 Prozent die FDP auf 6 die
AFD wurde wegen ihrer internen Spaltung
und konkurrierender Kandidatenliste in
Bremen von der Wahl ausgeschlossen davon
profitiert offenkundig die ähnlich
ausgerichteten BÜRGER IN WUT BIW sie
kämen auf zehn Prozent diese Zahlen sind
natürlich nur eine Momentaufnahme und
keine Prognose für den Wahlausgang
Stimmen und Stimmungen kurz vor der Wahl
hat keine Klage eingefangen
der Bremer Bürgermeister liebt die Bühne
und mag es den Ton anzugeben nach
jüngsten Umfragen kann der
Sozialdemokrat platz 1 von der CDU
zurückerobern und offenbar wählen ob er
Rot-Grün-Rot fortsetzen oder eine große
Koalition mit der CDU anstreben möchte
mit der CDU ist das schwer eine Politik
für soziale Gerechtigkeit zu machen da
muss man sich nur angucken was die CDU
zu Tarif Treue sagt oder zum
Ausbildungsfonds bei anderen Stellen
sich andere Fragen wie machen wir eine
Politik des Klimaschutzes die aber
niemanden überfordert Landwirt und CDU
Spitzenkandidat Frank Imhoff würde gern
die Politik in Bremen neu anschieben er
kann sich vorstellen mit der SPD
zusammenzukommen wenn noch nicht um
jeden Preis
ich habe keine Lust mehr mich ein
Problem einzurichten sondern ich möchte
gerne Probleme gelöst haben und das wird
in ein Koalitionsvertrag zu schreiben
sein und wenn das mit der SPD möglich
ist
dann ja okay aber wenn das mit den grün
möglich ist dann muss man darüber schon
sprechen doch laut Politbarometer
gedeihen keine schwarz-grünen
Blütenträume bundespolitisch gab es
zuletzt Gegenwind für die Grünen und in
Bremen Verdruss über Baustellen zur
autofreien Innenstadt der noch trotz
grüner Verluste müsste es für die
jetzige Koalition reichen
haben wir
gut zu arbeitet Hand in Hand wieder
zusammengearbeitet und haben trotz
Pandemie trotz Energiekrise als
rot-grün-roter Senat auf viel bewegt die
Spitzenkandidatin der Linken bekam als
Wirtschaftssenator und viel Anerkennung
auch weil sie gut durch die Pandemie
führte sie setzt ebenfalls auf eine
Fortführung des linksbündnisses
wenn sich die ceduso aufstellt und dann
auch noch mit dem Personal gehe ich
davon aus dass die Genossen unserer
Schwesterpartei von einer groko auch
Abstand nehmen und ich kann auch ehrlich
gesagt dazu nicht raten wir sehen das
gerade in Berlin die groko ist kaum
vereinigt und dann werden schon die
Mieten für die kommunalen MieterInnen
erhöht
FDP-Spitzenkandidat Tore Scheck arbeitet
im Wahlkampf an seiner Bekanntheit
offenbar um wieder über die 5% Hürde zu
springen auch weil die Liberalen mit dem
Thema innere Sicherheit und Attacken auf
die CDU ihr Profil stärken die CDU in
Bremen im Moment gibt sich sehr
bürgerlich ist aber in ihrem
Wahlprogramm grüner als die Grünen die
ist in der derzeitigen Verfassung eine
Mogelpackung die Wählervereinigung
BÜRGER IN WUT sieht sich als
Sammelbecken für Protestwähler und
profitiert mit deutlichen
stimmengewinnen davon dass die AFD
aufgrund von antragsfehlern zur Wahl
nicht zugelassen wurde eine konservative
Politik wird unabhängig davon was er
vorher gewählt hat ob CDU oder AFD hat
mit uns eine echte Alternative über die
Zusammensetzung der Bremischen
Bürgerschaft entscheiden die Wählerinnen
und Wähler an diesem Sonntag
hat aber dir geht es jetzt mit dem
Bahnstreik weiter ja und der hat es in
sich 50 Stunden lang soll auf
Deutschlands Bahnschienen ab
Sonntagabend so gut wie gar nichts mehr
gehen das hat die Gewerkschaft EVG heute
angekündigt um den Druck in den
Tarifverhandlungen noch mal ordentlich
zu erhöhen die Auswirkungen für die
Fahrgäste sind massiv aber Valerie
Haller die EVG will mit diesem langen
Streik auch die Wirtschaft treffen ja
das sagt sie wie stark wird man sehen
aber klar ist dieser Streit belastet
nicht nur die Bahn und ihre Kunden er
trifft auch viele andere den
europäischen Güterverkehr beispielsweise
denn etliche frachtkorridore führen nun
mal durch Deutschland und dabei sind
viele Unternehmen auf pünktliche
Lieferungen angewiesen ja und jeder
Container der steht der kostet eben auch
Geld ebenfalls betroffen sind
Privatbahnen weil ja auch Stellwerke
bestreicht werden einige Ökonomen halten
den Schaden insgesamt für überschaubar
die häufigen Streiks aber sagen sie
schaden dem Image das
Wirtschaftsstandorts Deutschland wo hakt
es denn momentan genau bei den
Verhandlungen die Fronten sind schon
ziemlich verhärtet seit Wochen hat sich
in den Verhandlungen ja kaum etwas
bewegt die Bahn hatte zwar nachgebessert
die Forderungen der EVG sind aber immer
noch deutlich höher das Angebot der Bahn
acht bis zehn Prozent mehr Gehalt dazu
eine Einmalzahlung bei 27 Monaten
Laufzeit die Gewerkschaft fordert aber
zwölf Prozent ab sofort mindestens 650
Euro mehr bei nur 12 Monaten Laufzeit
die EVG räumt der Bahn noch eine
Möglichkeit einen Streik abzuwenden
dafür muss sie aber bis spätestens
Freitag ein besseres Angebot auf den
Tisch legen ob das allerdings klappt
höchst unsicher
vielen Dank Valerie für diese
Einordnungen
die Zahl der firmenleiten in Europa ist
im vergangenen Jahr deutlich angestiegen
grund dafür waren laut der Auskunft bei
Kreditreform vor allem die hohen
Energiekosten und Rohstoffpreise aber
auch die schwache Konjunktur und
gestiegene Zinsen besonders betroffen
war Osteuropa mit einem Plus von rund
53% bei den Unternehmensinsolvenzen in
Westeuropa lag der Anstieg bei rund 24%
Pflegekräfte waren im vergangenen Jahr
so häufig krankgeschrieben wie noch nie
zuvor das zeigen Daten der Techniker
Krankenkasse im Schnitt fehlten
Beschäftigte in der Pflege
28,8 Tage das sind rund 57% mehr als der
Durchschnitt aller anderen bei der TK
Versicherten Erwerbstätigen häufigster
Grund für die Fehltage waren psychische
Erkrankungen und Atemwegsinfekte der
Rekordwert verdeutliche wie stark die
Berufsgruppe belastet sei erklärte der
stellvertretende Vorstandsvorsitzende
Ballast
als die Ukraine mit dem Carlos Orchestra
den letzten Eurovision Song Contest
gewann hofften viele Ukraine noch dass
der nächste ESC tatsächlich in der
Ukraine ausgetragen würden zumindest
wollten sie sich an der Hoffnung
festhalten
manche Mutmacher Fantasien machten die
Runde eine ESC Beachparty auf der Krim
das wäre es
der ESC hat für die Ukraine nichts zum
ersten Mal eine politische Dimension die
Siegerin von 2004 russlana wurde zu
Aktivistin der Orangenen Revolution und
des euromidern und 2016 gewann die
Sängerin Jamala mit dem Lied 1944 das
von der Vertreibung der Krim Tataren
unter Stalin handelt
2017 konnte der ESC daraufhin noch in
Kiew stattfinden diesmal nicht die im
letzten Jahr Zweitplatzierten Briten
sind Ersatz Gastgeber in Liverpool
Andreas Stamm berichtet
das war's von uns und gegen 0.30 gibt es
dann unser heute journal Update mit
Gundula Gause morgen auf Wiedersehen und
einen angenehmen Abend noch
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter eine umfangreiche
Hochdruck Brücke bildet sich aus vom
Atlantik bis zum Baltikum und dabei
erreicht uns relativ warme Luft und die
ist sogar im Norden wärmer als im Süden
Europas bis zu 25 Grad hier Richtung
Skandinavien und ja teilweise nur um die
20 Grad Marke nach Süden hin schauen wir
uns die Details an in der Nacht gibt's
Regen vom Rheinland bis Richtung
Bayerischer Wald im Südwesten sind auch
Gewitter dabei sonst bildet sich Nebel
und dem Osten da bleibt es komplett
trocken die Temperaturen gehen zurück
auf vier Grad an den Alpen und 12 Grad
z.B Richtung Hamburg morgen dann sehr
viel Sonnenschein im Norden ja ansonsten
aber Schauer und Gewitter vor allem nach
Süden hin und auch in der Mitte das bei
Temperaturen bis 24 Grad nach Osten in
23 Grad immer noch auch Richtung Emsland
im Süden an den Alpen sind es 13 Grad
die nächsten Tage bringen weitere
Schauer und Gewittern vor allem am
Samstag dann in der Südhälfte nach
Norden ist es trocken weiterhin hier mit
Sonnenschein bei 14 bis 23 Grad am
Sonntag gibt's dann auch im Norden
Schauer und Montag wieder zahlreiche
Gewitter das bei 14 bis 22° und damit
wünsche ich Ihnen einen schönen Abend